i think in today's market more so than  ever i think this has always been  important but more so than ever it's  relationship builders it's people that  can go out and build strong  relationships with clients and  candidates alike and i think if you  couple that with strong work ethic  prioritization organization and just  consistency in what they do i personally  that's the recipe in today's market it's  changed in terms of recruitment used to  be very transactional ones and twos you  know get your numbers across the line  and now it's really looking at selling  proper solution selling to clients and i  think that takes a slightly different  kind of beast of personal skill set uh  in order to deliver it the recruitment  mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by  vincerie and the award-winning sauce  breaker